well what I say in this paragraph is
that the mail on Sunday ran an article
februari 2007 saying that my
relationship with my then girlfriend
Jemima Khan was on the rocks because of
my persistence late night flirtatious
phone calls with a plummy voiced studio
executive from Warner Brothers and it
was a bizarre story completely untrue
that I sued for libel over and and one
and damages rewarded a statement was
made in open court but I thinking about
how they could possibly come up with
such a bizarre left-field story I
realized that although there was no
plumbing voiced studio executive from
Warner Brothers within might end any
kind of relationship flirtatious or
otherwise there was a great friend of
mine in Los Angeles who's a runs
production company which is associated
with Warner Brothers and whose assistant
his a charming married middle-aged lady
English who as happens in Hollywood is
the person who rings you that the
executive never rings you it's always
their assistant hi we have you know jack
bailey on the phone for you and this was
what she used to do she used to cordon
she's leave message isn't because she
was a nice English girl in you know they
sometimes when we spoke we'd have a joke
about english stuff Marmite or whatever
and so she would leave charming jokey
messages saying please call the studio
executive back and she has a voice that
could only be described as plumbing so I
cannot for the life of me think of any
conceivable source for this story in the
mail on Sunday except those voice
messages on my mobile telephone well you
haven't said you haven't alleged that
before have you in the public domain no
but when I was preparing this statement
and going through all my old trials and
tribulations of the press I looked at
that one again I thought that is weird
and then the penny dropped I think the
last it can be put is frankly it's a
piece of speculation on your part
relation to this yeah you could
speculation okay but I would love to
know i mean i think mr. Kaplan who
represents associated was saying earlier
today that you know I'd like to put in a
supplementary statement and you know
referring to the things I say today what
I'd love to hear what the Daily Mail's
or the Sunday males explanation for that
article was what their source was if it
wasn't phone hacking